I don't trust the younger generation in
terms of values because I don't even
think they know what it is that they
value does the term swirling nowadays
okay boomer okay boomer okay boomer
trend it's going viral almost like a
demeaning term to older people the
Millennials and Generation Z have the
Peter Pan syndrome they don't ever want
to grow up this grievance culture as you
suggest that says the we're all owed
something from the world and if we don't
get it it's because the system has
failed us okay why can't you love me as
much as you love to share memes
[Music]
my name is Mike symfon Dora I'm 57 years
old from Bellflower California I got
four kids my name is Toni Jackson Walker
I'm from Los Angeles California I'm 65
years old my name is Jess I'm 20 and I'm
from Ventura California my name is
Corrine I'm 21 and I'm from East LA hi
my name is Stefan I'm also 21 and I am a
student and artist I'm bill I am a
writer and a dad of two and I'm a baby
boomer line up over on the left and my
gen Z over on the right okay boomer is
ageist
I think the phrase okay boomer is ages
because determine itself erases the
entire experience of a whole generation
if we as gens ears were to get that same
energy from boomers we would feel
ostracized and we would feel
marginalized I've never heard the term
okay but I feel like it's like just
missing something that someone says but
implying to someone who's a baby boomer
like if someone were to say oh I don't
like Starbucks you'd be like okay boomer
oh that's funny to me rather than
insulting I personally don't think it's
necessarily ageist because being a
boomer is more associated with certain
behavioral patterns and mindsets
and like potentially political views so
it's kind of more about the
characteristics of a boomer rather than
the age itself it's kind of like they're
like hold back in my day type language
and our response to back in my day is
okay when we're well we said that to our
parents too
do you have kids yes well we all have so
I wouldn't say something in something
about my kids generation because they're
all chinzy so I love my gen Z kids so I
wouldn't knock them for that they
couldn't help when they were born older
generations create problems that younger
generations have to solve speaking for
like at least myself and a lot of my
close friends I feel as though there
have been a lot of issues that we've had
to kind of take on such as the
environment such as a lot of wars that
we had nothing to do with yet we have to
end up with like the repercussions no I
would agree and I do think that's sort
of true of every generation you have to
deal with the world that your parents
gave you when my children were born
there were enough cellphones my daughter
was born in 2001 and just in that 18
years you know 19 years almost that she
been alive the whole world has changed
radically and it's scary for us as
parents because my generation
technically gave that to your generation
and it has changed not only your
generation but ours too in terms of the
time that we have for each other
everybody sitting around doing this you
know when you're all sitting in a room
together and that's us too if there were
anything I wish we could dial back a
little bit it would be that all the
older generations may have created those
problems I don't think they did it on
purpose the hindsight is 20/20 so once
you see the effects of what you've done
I don't necessarily think it's just the
younger generations cleaning up the
problems I do believe that the older
generations offer support as well I
think historically there are issues that
are inherent in each generation because
there are certain things they'll always
be war and there'll always be poverty
but it doesn't necessarily mean that a
generation created it and another
generation is going to come and solve it
because I don't believe it will ever be
solved in essence it will be something
as perpetrated and ongoing it's always
gonna be this way my parents left
problems for us to solve we're gonna
leave problems for you to solve I think
it comes down to what do we do about it
because it takes a lot of leadership to
go I don't think what I've been doing or
been a part of has been very helpful but
I want to try to earn the right to help
fix it I trust the values of the other
generation
[Music]
I do just as much I may question some of
the values that they're talking about
one of these that personally bothers me
we've allowed communism to become an
acceptable thought process in this
country to govern us which also tells me
we haven't done our job but yet when you
look at why is it brought up it's
because people feel enormous we
frustrated and we need to address the
people in our age bracket why are they
frustrated and how do we change some of
that they grew up in a different world
than we did yes when I got out of
college I got a job I got an apartment I
was able to live by myself and you could
do that then the world that our children
are coming into it's not nearly as easy
to do because of the price of housing
because of the sort of wages they can
get there aren't companies that you can
go and enter now at twenty one or two
and know that you're gonna work for 40
years for that company when I grew up I
knew what my beliefs and my values were
gonna be because my mother passed down
the same ones that my grandmother had I
passed on the same ones to my son now I
think somewhere in between the
generations between you all and us
things have changed we stopped talking
we stopped saying what we value I don't
trust the younger generation in terms of
values because I don't even think they
know what it is that they value do you
value another person's life I tell my
son oh my god when the worse things can
happen to me is someone in this
generation would have to take care of me
they don't understand me they don't know
anything about me that goes to the
prompt which is do you trust the other
side's values and I think the values
that you may have grown up with in terms
of what you were taught about being
homosexual and whatnot good I grew up
queer in a black family that's a whole
different dynamic and what they were
taught that was brought down to them
intergenerationally
have been homophobia and it's like
that's what I think of when I think of
values of my elders and I can't trust it
because in terms of policy it was your
generation I got it wrong so many times
and that have put LGBTQ people in to a
second-class status and we're trying to
get that back as our generation I'm not
really even sure what like the values of
baby boomers are like what they would
agree on are but I do appreciate all the
work that has been done for us by that
generation like civil rights women's
rights like LGBT rights I was born with
all those rights but it was really the
people that were a lot of them baby
boomers in those protests that got me
where it got us where we are today I was
a young gay boy and couldn't even say
the word until I was in my 20s it was
the most horrible thing you could
imagine growing up to me I couldn't talk
to anybody about it yeah I mean I'm gay
and there's so much progress that has
been made but there's still so much to
be made when I think of values of like
baby boomers the first thing that I
think of is kind of just the holy hard
work gets you pretty much anywhere
mindset and I just feel like that's so
toxic because there are so many other
barriers that a lot of people don't talk
about like if you're poor if you have
like kids if you don't have
opportunities for education like those
three just alone will inhibit your
success well I think that was true when
we were young hard work did get you very
far my husband worked in a company which
he started in his 20s and worked there
for many years it was just an
established company with a you know
retirement plan and all this sort of
thing and those don't exist anymore your
generation doesn't have those guarantees
and I think that is why you're seeing
such a large scale rejection of
capitalism and I don't think it's
communism I think what our generation is
exploring now is socialism which is not
the same as communism you guys inherited
a
an economy that works for working people
we are inheriting a gig economy for
subcontractors that only works for the
rich and powerful when our generation is
exploring is democratizing the workplace
and social justice things like that that
are really for the people which is at
the core of what socialism is we are
growing up in a different country then
you guys are growing up in and we are
looking for alternatives because we know
this is not sustainable
I believe my generation will leave the
world a better place I hope you do too I
plan on fighting to do our part that
when I part that you've inherited things
that have improved and then I hope when
you leave the earth you've made it even
better and handy because if we don't
game over and that may be a dramatic
term but I tell people you know mileage
we don't have a choice do we leave it
better or worse it's an obligation let
me put it this way you're gonna know we
were here we laid a foundation for you
all to come and do bigger greater things
civil rights women's rights boycotts
we fought for everything and we're still
working we're still making changes and I
think this generation will leave making
a better place because of everybody
else's work my family always says like
in terms of raising kids with your
parents you take what you like and you
lose what you don't so I think we have
such an advantage with the internet
being able to see what was done wrong
generations ago and what we can do now
to fix it I want to believe that and I
have a lot of hope that we will and I
feel like we have the potential but
knowing what I know about history a lot
of what we're experiencing today are
just new renditions of what we've
already experienced and we know that
history repeats itself we just don't
know when to call it and
it's oftentimes when we call it it's too
late knowing what I know about the
environment and what's really going to
happen it's like I can't realistically
say that when I in good conscience we
want to like bring a new generation into
this world and knowing that it will be a
better world for them we can't save the
world we can only say guess what we were
here we made a change we attempted to do
good and we attempted to help others and
become more diverse and if we did that
you know what we did something
collectively individually we made the
world a better place I'm believing great
things for you